when I tell you parenting is just like
politics right now we've gone way too
extreme and everybody has to get to the
middle as fast as humanly possible so
it's like hey kid there's unlimited
people that don't know anything at 17.
the world is filled with people that
sucked at school and don't know what
they want to do comma you're not going
to be laying at home doing nothing right
so you don't need to go to school but
you're going to work and by the way if
you want to work at Walmart good if you
want to be an entrepreneur fine you but
but you're gonna have to do that and
yeah I got you because I love you and
you can stay here but I'm not giving you
any money here's where parents get
caught they talk big game but they one
of the parents undermines the whole Ship
by slipping them 100 bucks quietly and
be like you can't do that if that kid's
such a big boy and he's going to do it
without school he needs to stand on his
own two feet parents undermine their
words with their actions you need to
make them stand on his own two feet that
will teach him everything and you but
you could be absolutely emotionally
supportive just not financially support